[Music]
all right now let's move on to a family
you definitely don't want to mess with
I'm talking about the crew of DC Comics
Justice League in Holy Week can take you
behind the scenes it was really
important that she would be the glue of
the team don't engage alone do this
together
joining gal gadot's Wonder Woman in this
super human team of five Game of Thrones
alum Jason Momoa as Aquaman Ezra Miller
as the flash ray Fisher is cyborg and of
course Ben Affleck is better this movie
starts with you know Bruce actively
recruiting and looking and researching
and trying to find these superhumans
that he believes are out there how many
of you are there I don't know it's not
met with enthusiasm by everybody
encounters you know some people are a
little bit more reluctant to join up be
part of the team just looking bad
digging for Jason playing a superhero
was a total bucket list mommy he
actually kind of geek out when you get
to see everyone they look unbelievable
like it's truly fanboying on that it's
cool the 38 year old trained hard for
the role which requires shirtless scenes
like this he even snuck in workouts on
set between tapes when you put
everything on whether it's holding the
try it in put the eyes in put the
costume on you're right into the
character
on set and when we're together it's like
a big family we didn't have one problem
no egos no drama
this is crazy honestly I think we're all
gonna die there's these great comedic
moments it's super action-adventure
we're all over the place a lot sets and
then it's a whole world that you can
just a machine
[Music]